let's say that Y is equal to five minus
three X over x squared plus three X and
we want to figure out what is the
derivative of Y with respect to X now it
might immediately jump out at you that
look-look Y is being defined as a
rational expression here as the quotient
of two different expressions we could
even view this as two different
functions you could view this one up
here as U of X so you could say this is
the same thing this is the same thing as
U of X over you could view the one in
the denominator as V of X so that one
right there is V of X and so if you're
taking the derivative of something that
can be expressed in this way as the
quotient of two different functions well
then you could use the quotient rule and
I'll give you my little aside like I
always do the quotient rule if you ever
forget it it can be derived from the
product rule and we have videos there
because the product rule is a little bit
easier to remember but what I can do is
just say look dy DX with if Y is just U
of x over V of X I'm just going to
restate the quotient rule this is going
to be this is going to be the derivative
of the function in the numerator so d DX
of U of x times the function in the
denominator times V of X - - I'll do the
- the function in the numerator U of x
times the derivative of the function in
the denominator times D DX V of X and
we're almost there and then over over
the function in the denominator squared
so this might look messy but all we have
to do now is think about well what is
the derivative of U of X what is the
derivative of V of X and we should just
be able to substitute those things back
into this this expression we just wrote
down so let's do that so the derivative
with respect to X of U of X of U of X
is equal to let's see 5 minus 3x so the
derivative of 5 is 0 the derivative of
negative 3x well that's just going to be
negative 3 that's just negative 3 if any
of that looks completely unfamiliar to
you I encourage you to review the
derivative properties and maybe the
power rule and now let's think about
what is the derivative with respect to X
derivative with respect to X of V of X
of V of X well derivative of x squared
we just bring that exponent out front
it's going to be 2 times X to the 2
minus 1 or 2 X to the first power or
just 2 X and then the derivative of 3x
is just 3 so 2x plus 3 and now we know
everything we need to substitute back in
here the derivative of U with respect to
X this right over here is just negative
3 V of X this we know is x squared plus
3x we know that this right over here is
V of X and then U of X we know is 5
minus 3x 5 minus 3x the derivative of V
with respect to X we know is 2x plus 3
2x plus 3 and then finally V of X we
know is x squared plus 3x so this is x
squared plus 3x and so what do we get
well we are going to get and it's going
to look a little bit hairy it's going to
be equal to negative I'll focus so first
we have first we have this business up
here so it's negative 3 times x squared
plus 3x so I'm just going to distribute
the negative 3 so it's negative 3x
squared minus 9x and then from that we
are going to subtract the product of
these two expressions and so let's see
what that what's what is that going to
be well we have a 5 times 2x which is
10x of 5 times 3 which is 15 we have a
negative 3x times 2x so that is going to
be negative as 6x squared minus 6x
squared and then a negative 3x times 3
so negative 9x and let's see we can
simplify that a little bit 10x minus 9x
well that's just going to leave us with
X so if we 10x minus 9x is just going to
be X and then in our denominator we're
almost there in our denominator we could
just write that as X plus 3x x squared
plus 3x squared or if we want we could
expand it out I'll just leave it like
that x squared plus 3x squared and so if
we want to let's just simplify or
attempt to simplify this a little bit
it's going to be negative 3x squared
minus 9x and then let's see you're going
to have a negative minus X minus X and
then minus 15 and then minus negative 6x
squared so plus 6x squared all of that
all of that over x squared plus 3x
squared or x squared plus 3x squared I
should say it that way now let's see
this numerator I can simplify a little
bit negative 3x squared plus 6x squared
that's going to be positive 3x squared
and then we have we have other than
orange we have negative 9x minus an X
well that's going to be minus 10x minus
10x and then we have minus 15 so minus
15 and so there you have it
we finally have finished this is all
going to be equal to this is all going
to be equal to 3x squared minus 10x
minus 15 over x squared plus 3
x-squared and we are done